ciao
mio libro storie paurose a scuola di
misteri e ora disponibile in libreria e
online metti alla prova il tuo coraggio
leggilo e accumula tutti i punti della
sales nel libro
[Musica]
che è successo
marino danieli equa ma siamo a berlino
per lì non ho capito che cosa offre la
creatura la tua cercarli giardino io
non si muove proviamo a prenderlo dalla
sua che effetti
bravissimo e proprio il mio aiutante più
bravo ma non sorridiamo manoccio non ci
arriviamo sopra come facciamo prenderlo
merlino protino i fugazi per savarino
prendiamo dei pupazzi qualcosa tra via
posta
o no si è spostato dov'è guardatevi
anche voi intorno lo vedete lo vedete da
qualche parte
io vedrò
valentia tourbook ortona sopra ora non
riuscirò mai più a recuperarlo dalla
sopra come eri proprio
devo chiamare evitare altrimenti io non
riesco a prenderlo dall'italia d'italia
linea del freddo
sbrigativo vedo sta per capire credo e
tutti arriva al tiro mi fa schifo
d'avino prendilo su no si scherza oli de
moliner
rimettiamo dentro don ok così scomparirà
per sempre speso
dai piccolino vai pure 6 liberatevi
sempre qua sotto non aver paura di me
stai di pure si mirino del bravo tiene
anche turbone fermo così lo cattureremo
che da vivo il violino vicino casa
[Musica]
non parli nono posto non posso pure la
scatola che tu vorresti annotarle capire
che cos'è e forse treno che va pure ma
non puoi e pericolosissima bocchetti il
lucchetto mi manca il lucchetto dove ero
messo tutto rispetto chiediamo la festa
non deve uscire mai più da qua scampato
pericolo ora sotterriamo il baule così
non lo rivedremo mai più ok
se meglio se dormo un pochettino
buonanotte berlino
verità vita di anita ecco che cosa è
successo ho sentito dei rumori che i
rumori mi ricordo che è successo
qualcosa col baule ma c'era qualcosa nel
baule preso qualcosa nel baule ma mi
sento un po strana cosa statici arriva
nyt ha preso qualcosa nel baule che hai
preso mi ha voluto dalla finestra si
ebbe dai allora magari usciamo un attimo
fuori prendi una boccata d'aria
magari ti fa stare meglio ok andiamo dai
perché dobbiamo uscire settiche bellavia
fresco al programma la settimana che si
sta
sei andato
ho bisogno di stare un momento da storno
che tu vai a mangiare ci vediamo dopo
vi siete accorti che c'è qualcosa di
strano e senza strano ho paura che sia
stato colpi strano così d'acqua casomai
vitale sta arrivando alla porta credo
che col pipistrello che ho catturato nel
baule abbiamo fatto qualcosa forse
dovrei riaprire il pipistrello no troppo
pericoloso e di consultare il libro
storie paurose guardiamo una delle
schede creatura ma voi ce l'avete è ora
disponibile in tutte le librerie online
andati a prenderlo che non c'è e ora
vediamo se troviamo qualche informazione
il vampiro il vampiro può assumere altre
forme come la forma di un pipistrello
devo trovare un antidoto una soluzione
prima di trasformarmi del tutto fermi in
mezzo alla luce del sole forse succederà
qualcosa
[Musica]
uno mi sta trasformando allora come
faccio devo assolutamente nascondere i
denti abitare non deve vederli quando
avrò finito di trasformarli tra un
pericolo per lui devo fare qualcosa devo
trovare una soluzione presto il libro
[Musica]
no no lo di stramaccioni proprio niente
bojan ogni tanto molto bene ha ancora
non ti senti bene
no no non mi sento per niente andare
anzi penso di avere una forma di
influenza tu per contagio vada quindi è
meglio teti allontare il più possibile
influenza super contagiosi allontanati
aiuto si
articola il naso
entrambi
oppure tutti detestato dire come il
baule si sia stato e paure porte a
contagiarvi ma l'importante è che tu te
ne vai più lontano possibile bocchetti
punto qualcosa di caldo magari non si sa
se no grazie anzi cosa c'è per pranzo
nola tuo posto preferito agli occhi più
principe casa 100 non pronto
a ottimo allora io posso mangiare i due
piatti il mio il tuo patetico il
probabile appel parola ok non vedo l'ora
ha tolto soprattutto riguardo di un po
così magari ti passa c'è bisogno di una
tisana grande aiuta lo porto si aspetta
momento farmi controllare il baule ma ho
mai detto che se ne stava andando mai
meglio ancora non buon nell'acqua della
pasta io potrei contagiati
vado via
c'è mancato poco
e ora come fa sapere allora nascosta
vitale al tv bloccare la trasformazione
troviamo una soluzione insieme
vita
imita
mamma mia perché si è arrabbiata per
qualcosa di salute ha detto di lasciarmi
solo portato la tisana così a magari e
ti riprendi ti aiuta un pochettino con
la tosse
tosca completo se prima levi la tosse
ciò non ci facciamo starnuti vi avevi
freddo tutto oggi ha portato la tisana
così va bene lascia in pace devo parlare
con il mio 4 ore
tuo padrone ma cosa stai dicendo
stai parlando ste bisbigliando al baule
si è il proprio ratio cioè ho ragione io
che stai bisbigliando al baule non
capisco
atleta che brucia
strumento non do nessuna parte prego
accomodati pure
ok ma come mai sei cambiata così tanto
prima voleva rimanere da sola adesso mi
sento molto meglio
ti senti molto meglio se un po
inquietante perché non lo so mi stai mi
stai fissato quegli occhi giganti
rottamare la tazza di tisana calda del
mio padrone vuole parlarti mio padrone
sì ho visto che per ripassare la
parlando ma perché c'è
questo progetto
si no sono usciti fuori quindi
d'agostino
questa volta mi è scappato ma la
prossima volta diventerà un banchino
come me vero padrone
[Musica]
presto ti libererò quando farò stanco
abbastanza per te ti libererò molto
presto
nascondiamoci mescoliamoci secondo qui
avete visto aveva quei denti lunghissimi
si stanno trasformando che adesso che
cosa faccio la spesa aspetta vita nel
pensaci pensarci perché la scheda
creatura vi ricorda qualcosa bravo un
bambino quindi la scheda da creature dei
vampiri nel libro storie favolose
ho letto che l'aglio può aiutare a
tenere lontano i bambini forse e meglio
sarà da prendere nella yo ora che ci
penso magari e posso mangiare un pezzo
così
sono ancora al sicuro qui nel
nascondiglio ho preso dell'aglio stavo
pensando che magari questo però conservo
per dopo per tirarmi addosso in caso
caso dovesse servire e questo mangiamolo
che ci siamo il mio piano è entrare in
camera prendere le paure perché ha detto
che all'interno c'era una creatura e poi
prenderemo anche libro in modo tale che
con il libro posso catturare la creatura
guardate
mio padrone prestiti
del sangue
prego si
sente odore di
sangue
[Musica]
solita ritornata per farti morti
sì certo come no anzi ti dirò di più ho
portato anche dello stadio
ma che sono più cattivo di agno penso al
tiro di aglio guarda ti dirò di più
di
questo lo prendo io lascia guardare sono
stati rosolare l'aglio ha funzionato
scappiamo
il libro che ritiene questo e tanto
meno la sua prima così viste poligrafo
ecco ci sono riuscito a sottrarre il
baule ad anita non sono vecchio come
sono riuscito a farlo probabilmente mai
mi aiutato tantissimo e o anche il libro
il libro storie paurose e voi ce l'avete
ma adesso cerchiamo subito la chiave
l'ho trovata e qui con la chiave possa
aprire il baule
[Musica]
no no